oh
une musique trois danseurs et 24 heures
pour créer sa chorégraphie darius alicia
et mari ne se connaissent pas n'ont pas
le même âge ni le même style de danse et
pourtant ils vont devoir faire équipe et
des de leur coach magali imagine tu
ensemble un spectacle sur une bande-son
imposer la musique avait été bal
commence par une boîte à musique
donc là pour le coup ça a donné tout de
suite l'idée d'une boîte à musique et
puis on est parti sur ce que pouvait
faire un magicien sont deux boîtes à
musique on réveille la poupée en force
l'essai le qui-vive en voilà et ça se
retourne contre le magicien qui finit
dans la boîte à musique
[Musique]
on a commencé pourra écouter la musique
ensemble à découper et voit qu'on ne
faisait penser chaque chaque moment
moment sur ce les moments un prolibre
moment saccadé pour et au fur et à
mesure chacun apporte ses idées
justement toi mais cette petite touche
est organisée par l'association thérapie
ce concours a réuni 17 participants six
équipes ont interprété leur chorégraphie
devant un jury composé de professionnels
du spectacle
notre trio a présenté sa création un
mélange entre danse et magie
[Musique]
malgré un problème d'accessoires et de
lumière l'équipe est plutôt satisfaite
du résultat et surtout de l'expérience
un truc chouette quand même un grand
moment de rencontre de partage acheter
un très très très très cool marrant de
danser avec des niveaux différents des
âges différents des disciplines
différentes
ils ont été au top malgré les malgré des
problèmes techniques
c'est super bien débrouillé après je les
ai vu que des coulisses donc je me suis
pas rendu compte de face en tout cas ils
sont éclatés franchement c'est c'est ce
qui est important
un investissement qui n'aura pas payé ce
coup ci ils sont arrivés en quatrième
position
les gagnants sont repartis avec un lot
de 500 euros darius alicia et marie
pourront retenter leur chance l'an
prochain mais cette fois peut-être pas
ensemble